My name is Rebecca
Hadi, and I'm here
today to tell you about a
time that I crashed a database
and I learned some techniques to
help from ever doing that again
that I'm going to
share with you.
I was working on the 31st
floor of an office building
in Downtown Seattle that had
a beautiful view of the Puget
Sound and Olympic Mountains.
I was working on the
marketing analytics team
at a large fashion
retailer, and I
was working on a project that
involved migrating marketing,
attribution, reporting from
our old clickstream vendor
to an in-house solution.
This involved doing a backfill.
Has anyone in the room
ever done a data backfill?
Yeah I see a few hands.
Has anyone ever had performance
issues with that backfill?
I certainly have.
So this project required
a backfill of a year
and a half of historical
clickstream data.
But at this time, I
had been a data analyst
for about three years and
through that time had written
SQL queries almost every day.
So naturally, I thought
I was an expert.
So I sat down at my desk,
put on my headphones,
turned on a score by Trent
Reznor and got to work.
I was working in an
Amazon Redshift database
with page view
level website data.
And for those of you who may
not be familiar with website
data, any time that you hover
or click or view a page,
it's generating data.
So you can imagine that that can
be a pretty large set of data
for a single person, not to
mention a website that has
millions of visitors a year.
In the past, I had worked at
health insurance companies,
and so I was used to working
with medical claims data,
and that data was more
in the millions of rows.
This data set was
4 billion rows.
So I had my query and I
sat I sat down at my desk
and I had my two monitors.
On the right hand side,
I had my SQL IDE, and I
set off my backfill,
and on my left monitor
I had some documentation
open that I was working on.
I updated some Jira tickets
and let's be honest,
checked my Twitter feed.
After getting sucked into
that for about 45 minutes,
I turned to my screen and I
noticed that my query was still
running.
And I thought, hmm, that
doesn't seem very good.
So I tried to cancel it, and I
got the rainbow wheel of death
and had to kill it.
And then I tried
to run it again.
And about an hour later,
there was still a problem. So
I tried to cancel it again.
And again, it crashed.
So I thought to myself,
what is going on with this?
I'm a SQL expert and
obviously my code is perfect,
so it can't be anything
that I'm doing.
On the 31st floor,
it held the entire data
science and analytics
team, which was about
100 people made up
of data analysts,
engineers and scientists.
So I thought it's probably just
a busy time on the database.
I'm probably running into
some concurrency issues
and it's just slow in general.
Then I had a brilliant idea.
I'll just run it at night.
Traffic on the
database will be low
and everything will be fine.
So I went home, took
the bus, and before I
went to bed that
night, I set off
my query to run into the night.
I woke up a little bit
early the next morning
to a Slack notification
on my phone
from the database administrator
who had never direct
messaged me before.
And all it said was, Hi.
Oh, fudge.
What have I done?
My heart sank because I knew
that something was wrong.
It turned out that
the query that I ran
ran for over seven hours.
And not only that, it
took compute resources
from other nightly
ETL jobs which
made them run slower, which
made them finish later,
which ended up delaying all
of our business reporting
for that day.
I was mortified.
I had not only made
my life harder,
I had made the database
administrator's life harder,
my team's life harder because
their stakeholders reporting
was delayed as well.
And needless to
say, the business
was not very happy with me.
But lucky for me, the
DBA reached out to me
and offered to help
me rewrite this query.
So I swallowed my
pride, walked down
to the 25th floor where
the engineering team sat,
pulled up a chair and
had a one hour meeting
that changed the course
of my SQL life forever.
And what I learned I'm going
to share with you today.
Imagine for a second that you're
going to explore a dark cave.
What items might you
want to help you?
For me,
I would want a map.
I would want to know
where I'm going.
Does this cave
even have an exit?
How many tunnels are there?
I would also want a
team or a cavern crew.
I would want people to help
carry equipment and make
the journey easier.
It's also very
dark in this cave.
So a flashlight would
be helpful to be
able to see where I'm going.
An Explain
Plan is like a map.
It returns a step by
step list of actions
that your query will take
to return your data set.
It also returns the
estimated computational cost
of that query.
It's very easy to run.
You only have to put the word
explain in front of your query
and run it.
The first time I saw
an explain plan,
I was very overwhelmed.
I swear my head exploded.
But it turns out that
it's a very helpful tool
because that
computational cost can
help you understand if
changes that you're making
to your query are helpful.
So in my instance, where I would
run my query, wait an hour,
kill it, run it, wait
an hour, kill it.
If I had run explain plans,
I could see that the changes
that I would make,
that I was making
would reduce the
computational cost
without having to
wait that extra hour.
So explain
plans are very useful. For
our cavern crew or cave team,
we want everyone to be
contributing equally.
We don't want one
person to be carrying
all of the backpacks
and the other people
to not be carrying anything.
That doesn't seem, one very
nice, or two very efficient.
From a query perspective,
compute nodes
are like your cave team.
You want all of
your compute nodes
contributing equally
and leveraging
all of their resources.
To make sure that happens, you
need to appropriately specify
the distribution style.
Distribution means that
your data is properly
distributed across
the compute nodes
and does not have
significant skew.
But how do you do that?
How do you know
what's the right
distribution style?
You think about which column
you're going to join on.
If you're planning on joining
on a unique ID, such as an order
ID or a customer ID, then dist style
key is what you want to use.
And the choice of your dist
key depends on which column
you are going to use to
join to another data set.
Dist style all is
very dangerous.
It copies your data across
each of the compute nodes.
So in the case where
you're not going
to join your table
to anything ever,
and it's a small data
set, you can get away
with dist style all.
But I personally
wouldn't recommend it.
And if you're not sure what
you're going to join on,
maybe you have a table
that's a lot of rows,
but it doesn't have
a good, unique ID
or a candidate for a distkey.
And maybe it's a
combination of fields that's
making it have a lot of rows.
Then dist style even
is a good candidate.
And the beauty of
the explain plan
is that when we make
these changes to our table
and try to run our query,
we can run an explain
plan to know if those changes
actually made a difference.
So caution with dist style all.
Your sort key is
like a flashlight.
It helps you only
search relevant data.
Imagine that you have a data set
that has three years of data,
2020, 2021 and 2022.
I only care about 2022.
I'm living in the present.
So I have a where I have a
WHERE clause that filters
on WHERE year equals 2022.
And my results set
would be filtered.
However, if I am not, if
the table I'm querying from
does not have a sort key,
even though my results
set is filtered it,
the query had to
scan the entire table
to find it, which is
not very efficient.
And so when you
specify a sort key,
it helps your query
know immediately
where to find the data
that you're looking for.
So it reduces the
computation needed
to pull back your results set.
To decide on a sort key,
you think about which
column you will filter on.
A lot of times that's a date.
This is an example
of the data set
that I was working with
on that fateful night when
I ruined everything.
There's a user ID, a session ID,
an event ID and an event time.
There's also an event
type and a marketing tag.
I was working on the
marketing analytics team.
And so I cared about traffic
and sales driven by marketing.
Based on what we just learned,
we know that
distribution style key
is a good fit for
this table because it
has unique identifiers.
But which unique identifier
would we choose as a dist key?
The answer is it depends.
If I was keeping the
data set at this level,
I would want to join.
I would want to specify the
dist key as the most granular ID.
I with using this data
set, I would likely
join on the event
ID to another table.
So therefore it
should be the dist key.
Pulling together everything
that we have learned.
On the left hand
side, I have a query
that takes that page view
level data that we were just
looking at and aggregates
it to the session level.
If you can imagine
landing on a website,
you can have multiple page
views during a session.
And so I cared
about what marketing
is at the session level.
And so when I'm creating
it, this temporary table,
I've specified my
distribution style as key
and I've specified my
dist key as session ID
because that's what
I'm going to use
to join to another data set.
So I know that all
my compute nodes
will be contributing equally.
I also have my flashlight or my
sort key on session start time
because that's what I'm going
to use when I end up filtering
from this temporary table.
On the right, I have a query
that leverages the table
that I just created and joins
it to another table called
web orders.
And I'm joining to that table
on user ID and session ID.
The because we have
specified session
ID as a distribution key,
all of the compute nodes
will be used in this join
and it will make it run
much more efficiently.
Because we have the sort
key specified as session
start time,
I'm filtering on anything
greater than January 1st
of 2022, and so
therefore my query
doesn't have to search for data
that it doesn't care about.
And we've saved
time there as well.
We've run our query,
we have our results set
in a reasonable amount of time.
We've made it to the light
at the end of the tunnel.
And the other side of the
cave, which is a big one.
Some other wins that came
out of this experience.
For one, my query that had
run overnight for seven hours
ended up running
in under one hour
during a high traffic
time on the database.
So ultimately the runtime was
reduced by 6 hours because
of these changes.
I also built a
strong relationship
with the database
administrator that
was very useful for future
cross-functional projects
between the data science team
and the engineering team.
But my favorite lesson came
from I documented my findings.
And I shared it
back with my team.
I helped them learn
these techniques
and apply them to
their own queries
to avoid making the
mistakes that I made.
And through that process
of sharing my experience
with my team, it also
helped me have a paradigm
shift towards embracing
mistakes because mistakes,
even very business
negative impacting
ones, can help you learn a lot.
So if you find yourself
with a long running query,
there are a few
things you can do.
You can run an explain plan.
You can check the
distribution style
and you can specify sort keys.
And that is how you
can save hours of time
with just a few lines of code.
Thank you.